okay
okay good afternoon everybody and
welcome to this meeting of the
um executive we have quite a full agenda
in terms
of um the business on there so we will
make a start
um attendances i'm not aware of any
apologies
um so we'll move on to item two which is
questions from
members of the public we have received
four questions
from members of the public or relating
to um item nine on the agenda so what i
propose to do
is to um either hear or read out those
questions now
as appropriate and if the residents are
based on whether or not the residents
are with us
but then to provide answers to those
questions
when we reach item nine so that the
executive have the responses fresh in
their mind before
um deliberating on those so um
i don't know if we have anybody any
residents waiting to come on at
all ian or joe i've not identified jane
lester or richard
jojo at the moment i can see
there are a couple of people
unidentified
on the list currently
i'm not sure if you're aware ian of
anyone
sorry not aware of the residents being
in the meeting
otherwise joel says there are some
people with numbers against the name
okay thanks what i will do is i will
read out the first two questions which
are from people that i didn't think that
we were expecting and then if we've got
questions three and four um at the point
when i reach those we will
um obviously give them a chance to ask
them themselves if not i will ask
the um i will read out the questions
thanks
okay so um question one is
from um denise labour who would like to
question why trafford council is adding
to the anxiety
resulting from these unprecedented times
of the global pandemic
of the hail community by wanting to
proceed with the hail village plan
despite multiple inaccuracies and many
changes since the initial consultations
and with the added in source of the
community not being listened to
or having taken into account the various
consultations and documentation
provided by other stakeholders local
businesses and the wider community
so that is the first question the second
question that we have received is from
bill clark why is trafford council
behaving in such an undemocratic way
to force through a deeply unpopular plan
for hail
that is likely to damage the village
beyond measure in
a time of such unprecedented crisis
and change and forgive me whilst i
retrieve
question three from my file
has has jane arrived at all
i'm going to presume i can't see
anyone identifiable leader um
there's a number of people if they could
identify themselves
for us please there's someone listed as
three
oh seven nine six double zero that's
council of haddad
okay there's three oh zero eight nine
five seven nine i think that's the cheap
exact
okay apologies i just asked if you could
just change me
uh to my name thank you okay
there's three zero nine zero one four
six um
so i am unsure on that one because the
camera is off
likewise with seven five seven zero
sorry am i supposed to um identify
myself okay it's all right denise it's
just showing us you as your counselor
thank you
okay well we'll presume not anyway let's
move on with with the questions so
um the question from jane lester
is in um three parts as follows relating
to
agenda item nine again one residents
keep telling me they are worried about
road safety and hails a hail plan
removes a signal pelican crossing and
replaces it with the sort of confusing
crossings we have on stanford new road
why has this choice been made when these
crossing points have created a lot of
difficulties in altering them
they cause confusion about who has right
of way and issues with accessibility
water quality impact assessment has been
done and will use the textile paving and
other accessibility features comply with
all relevant international
and national standards two we need to
support our local businesses by giving
people choices about how they get around
their area and move freely
on page 38 of the hail plan under the
movement objective
states to support the improvement of
accessibility to and within the centre
for pedestrians and cyclists
and to encourage sustainable means of
transport why in detailed objectives
with the rest of the plan are there no
proposals to create segregated cycle
ways
and three in november 2018 traffic
council declared a climate emergency
whereby the council uh consider the
climate emergency impacts of each area
of the council's activities
given that commitment why do the hail
and sail more place plans not have the
need to create a development
that supports action on climate change
as a central purpose so that
is our third question and finally
the fourth question is from richard jojo
why have the executive council failed to
warn advise inform
allow consultation or allow any input
into this ill-conceived place plan
for the village of salem or the village
of salem and all its businesses are
horrified by the underhanded and covert
action that is taking place without our
knowledge and we are asking why
um the council are behaving in this
covert manner so those are the four
questions
received for ease of um clarity of
response we'll take those at item
nine so that they're crashing the
executive members minds when we consider
that item okay so that's item two
item three is declarations of interest
are there any declarations of interest
no okay item four um
is minutes of the previous um
meeting of the 20th of july are we happy
to
receive and approve those i
thank you item five is matters from
council already with you and scrutiny
committees i'm not aware of any
no okey doke item six
then our first substantive item on the
agenda
is traffic climate emergency progress
report councillor i've said please
thank you uh leader can you hear me
yes thank you all right sorry to check
on that i've had a lot of problems with
me computers today so uh
hopefully it's uh something to sort it
out for now so yes sir on front changes
uh i'd first like to pay my personal
thanks
to officers for the amount of time spent
putting together this
very comprehensive report which i'm sure
members will find to be
very positive and helpful and i think it
does for the first time
start to pull together a lot of the work
we've been doing around the different
areas
but in a more joined up way and then the
proper strategy that everyone can see in
a single report
covering many many aspects of that work
and obviously this will all help
contribute
i was moving forward some have suggested
previously that nothing's been happening
so i think clearly when you read through
the report you can actually see that
simply not true so i think we can put
that one to rest right now
obviously uh this report is the starting
point in our strategy for dealing with
climate change and zero carbon work
of course we're working to a number of
different deadlines including 2050
nationally
and locally at 20 30 across gm
i think obviously we're going to also
build upon the
strategies that council has previously
had from 2008 and 2013
quite detailed within the report what
you may find is interesting that i've
certainly found it quite an opener
is that obviously buildings in all
buildings count for 75
emissions which is by far the highest of
of everything
and okay and some 20
of the earth next total is all forms of
transport with the remaining
five percent being some forms of waste
so what's interesting about that
that actually helped drive our way
forward clearly uh well we've got to
focus on all areas i think clearly
working on all types of buildings will
be a huge priority
as well on that one and working across
the different organizations public
private business
and obviously residential as well to try
and actually help with all the different
aspects of that
i think more interestingly there were i
think quite positive
was a in the latest reports i sat out in
section two
from june of this year it does show a
downward trend since 2018
and whilst that's a pleasing start it
isn't by no means error
anything that we need to sort of settle
to that and clears a huge task in front
of us
to carry and get this work done as
you'll note from
section 3 following the green summit
last year which i would add i did attend
and that one trafford has fully
committed to playing his part
in this work at gm level as well as
locally and through many of our
partnerships
section 4 says that in detail the
response to the scrutiny task and
finnish working group
and at very detailed section five
setting out much that work today
and many of those areas are actually my
own portfolio and it's detailing some
really good progress on how many of
those items
as you also know leader uh interestingly
the clean air plan
is on the next item on this agenda
something like some very positive
aspects out there
however i think we do have to simply say
this is a good start and that's what it
just is it is just to start
and obviously we have to know move
forward and i think that's section seven
sets out from those findings that we
need to look at and the framework to
actually
help our understanding of the work
moving ahead including the targets we
need to achieve
and also recognize the role of partners
particularly in business residential and
others which obviously
we could not hope to achieve our goals
without their support of and their input
and there was obviously a lot of detail
i set out an appendix one which was
developed by
and thesis which ensure members will
actually find a very useful guiding tool
as we move forward in this work
certainly it's a huge piece of work
within that
entity system and really good work and
while some of the criticized language
sampsons have been taken
i think we actually did need to step
back and actually set out the deposit we
could
just come in jumping and running about
and doing things but i think really to
really sit down and actually think about
what we need to and a good starting
point i think that's the main point
that good starting point gives us where
to actually go to would you simply come
in
and actually took this time aside we
would not be in a good position to
actually
start we are now a lot of our partners i
think it's clearly south out there
i think obviously got the action plan
set out in appendix 2
i think the government's arrangements
are set out in section 9 which i'll be
looking at discussing with officers
urgently because we need to get a lot of
this set up as soon as we can
i think i'm also pleased to note as well
obviously uh we're now we're involved in
getting the uh
the the gm level uh set up there on the
city region board
i think unfortunately a lot of this work
like a lot of things this year has been
delayed
quite rightly because of covid and it's
quite like we get that sorted out i
think now
is this time for getting getting on with
this world and getting us back on course
with this so
so obviously one sensor coverage has
affected certainly make no apologies for
that
we're obviously quite pleased that we
actually got the right strategy in place
and while it has taken some time
i think it is the right strategy now to
take us forward thank you with that
leader i'll leave at that and take any
questions thank you
thank you councillor aunt's head outside
any questions or comments from
members of the executive
okay before i open this out more widely
councillor freeman
thank you leader just to add to what
steve has said
this is basically a good news story it
is a start
but it should be acknowledged as a good
news story thank you leader
thank you councillor freeman so i will
open out more widely now members will
note that there is a significant
attendance from members of the council
outside of the executive committee
tonight
i don't intend to restrict the number of
contributions but obviously if i need to
do so to ensure that we finish
um before 6 pm then i then i will do so
so people can have that
in mind from the start that will
hopefully mean that we can spend
um an even amount of time on all of the
um items on the agenda
councillor coggins please thank you
chair
um i do want to welcome this report um
and echo counselor adsense comments to
thank
the officers i know of officer time has
gone into this as well as obviously the
anticipate
and actually thank all the parties
because this is a result of the green
uh motion supported by the lib dems and
actually but supported by
all four parties uh two two years ago
um i am slightly reeling to be honest
from cancer attest and cancer free man's
um
positive and upbeat um comments on this
and while i really welcome the report i
think it's really detailed it's really
what we need
and the information it actually contains
is extremely stark uh it tells us that
we have
seven years at our current rate to use
up our entire remaining carbon budget
and that we need to reduce by 13.4
percent
per year until we're down to zero i
i don't know if they've really taken in
the scale of the changes that are needed
for that
and obviously as we build back from
covert we need to
have this focusing our direction and
fortunately the kind of green changes we
need are also the ones that will
bring about social justice that will
support local businesses will protect
our green spaces and so on so
um really my questions are not about the
anthesis report which is very
uh substantial and very excellent and
about what we're doing
with it really about the um the
council's response and also about the
gaps in the anthesis report
and so the gaps of course are things
like um it we
still um doesn't deal with our uh
enormous
investment in the greater manchester
pension fund
uh especially in the um in the fossil
fuel industry
and it also doesn't deal with indirect
emissions so for example everything that
we eat in trafford and everything that
we bring into trafford and our travel
and so on is not covered
so i'm wondering first of all what the
council can do to
encourage changes in those other
behaviors and to support residents and
businesses to make those
so that's one question and i'll be ready
for my questions later
um and then the second set of questions
really are about accountability so we
have
not really a plan i realize it's only a
draft but it really is a very very
sketchy outline
for something that requires such
enormous changes across the whole
borough
and over such a small small small period
of time
so really we will need to see um this
being taken as seriously as our
financial budget we will need to see
quarterly and annual reporting on where
we're up to with our emissions
reductions
we'll need a clear chain of
responsibility like we have with our
financial reporting
names dates who's responsible for this
who's aiming
what are we aiming for um and also
planning ahead as looking at what the
obstacles might be
and how we might be able to get around
them so two sets of questions really
about how we're dealing with the things
that aren't included
and how we're going to have some
accountability and be absolutely sure
that we are on track
thank you thank you council copying's
counselor outside
please thank you yes thank you leader
thank you for those questions counselor
coggins
i think first of all uh on your question
about investment obviously that's what
we've got to take forward now and look
at this
and obviously as you read through the
report we'll be looking at a
second plot of partnerships and
obviously uh in trafford we have a
trafford park which is obviously a very
big contributor
to our carbon emissions as well as other
places like health service and modern
ones like that i think it's important we
get those partnerships up and running
as soon as possible so we can actually
all know exactly that the task that
they have in front of them as well as
front of us there i think it's very
important that we do get
this off the ground as quickly as
possible
i think there's a lot there's certainly
a lot to do in that area there i think
it's right we actually do that but i
think
it's something that we'll be doing over
the next few months and i think
obviously we're setting up our that
leads us on to the next question as well
i think
council recognized about the
accountability and that's they're going
to be ultimately important actually that
is i can quietly
uh that's something else that i say want
to personally obviously be very shortly
in that sense of it there so we can
actually uh look at the vengeance for
members how residents fit in how
businesses
partners uh can actually how we all
accountable to each other
uh obviously support your sets out very
basic amount of that as you pointed out
quite well it's not all in place yet
that's something i want to start
overseeing and then everyone immediately
following the meeting tonight
they said oh no my agenda starts
discussing those i think
all those things are together and it's
quite like we actually do tackle
you on the other point say about some of
the fossil emissions and that's often i
think we've got to get on top of this
quickly but
i think we need to write in partners one
of the things that i've always uh
found when i went to a session last year
i think quite interesting uh
where mostly companies can actually uh
sign off some of their admissions
by purchasing the dividends from a lot
of
the
places which i think there's a place for
that but i'm concerned that this carbon
offset in
uh it should be used in the right place
that's one of the things i want to look
at i think it's done lightly that's
probably a good
uh contributor i know from the we've
done with some of the forest uh
commissioners to sit on that they
obviously need that one is here to do
that
but it shouldn't necessarily be an
excuse for some particularly large
companies to actually uh
carry on as they are in that sense it's
not one of the things i would actually
want to see
come through that but hopefully that
answers some of those questions there
i've got all that [ __ ] because we
haven't got the group set up yet
but that will be our priority moving
forward
thank you councillor i've said are there
any other members who wish to come in on
this item
no okay so the recommendations are as
per um page one of the report and can
they be
uh approved please i'll move that line
thank you okay um item seven
is um back to council right again with
an update on the consultation for
the greatest manchester queen airplane
councillor outside
all right thank you ladies and gentlemen
this report
right yes thank you thank you at least
yes i'm quite pleased to bring the
support here tonight
obviously it's very detailed and very
comprehensive on the work today
and the progress of the gm clean air
plan i think that importantly
how we are to progress to the formal
public consultation starting next month
which i think is detailed in section 6.7
to 611 and it's actually the information
around it and actually how it complies
with
copyright and score guidelines given the
circumstances i think that's
particularly important
and this is part of what we got in this
current situation we'd hope by this
point in the year we could actually have
some proper
face-to-face consultations but that's
simply not possible and it was right and
proper and now is the time we actually
do get on with this
so we need to bring down those levels of
pollution and it's not that we have the
strategy in place i think it's also
working with our partners to ensure
that actually we got the conversation
when we got the statues in place and we
actually
uh have delayed it long enough it's
already been delayed by a year
in that century which which i think it
was right again that we actually did
that
actually we do need to get the air
quality improved
i think important as well it's how we're
going to discuss things like
impacted groups and actually what they
want to see and that's how we can work
with them
and this is obviously the formal
consultation very shortly where we can
actually look at doing a lot that
i think obviously in the report does
help details
around the charges for non-compliant
vehicles the exemptions the temp of
temporary
and the permanent exemptions further
when you
through the report further you see that
gm has been awarded some 36 million
pounds for the preparatory
implementation and contract arrangements
to deliver
the clean air zone as detailed and
obviously we've got some
clean some initial clean vehicle funds
for coaches
hgvs and private hire vehicles and also
including fronts actually retrofit buses
and because of our number of bosses
detailed in the report that cannot be
retrofitted not something we've got to
look at further with that
on another level of something we're
quite keen to do one
another area of concern though is that
whilst the government has accepted
need for replacement funds for hackney
carriages like goods vehicles
it has all requested further development
of shared evidence of the needs
within this complex sector before
responding to the pacifica
ask gm has submitted the information
however
at the time of writing this the
government has not made enough of
funding
gm will therefore need to consult on the
financial position
at the date of the consultation
currently the ask is 80 million pounds
for happy coverages and it is a
include 10.4 million pound uh which
includes lovely costs
i think in addition there are other
concerns around
those maintained by highways in england
including some trunk roads as well as
the motorway network
not being part of the proposals i'd like
to assure you that lobbying will
continue on this
it's something that been raised
continuously and we have the m60 going
through
right throughout through our uh brother
and it is actually a large contributor
to that something it's something that we
simply want to
work with that to make sure that if we
do keep that on the government agenda
once government has accepted
it is uh it is there i think it's
actually getting them to move on and
actually
accept that we need to include that in
the work we're actually doing
obviously another area of work that we
need to actually consistently make a
priority
is the impact assessment and actually
how that will actually impact them
on the on the affected groups
interestingly running us
alongside this the clean air plan is the
licensing minimum standards
are set out in section nine which gives
very comprehensive details which before
we please
what we're going into though at this
point uh actually i'm i'm actually
pleased it's actually included in the
report obviously as attached to private
high vehicles
or a significant part of gm's transport
offer
as well as providing and as well as find
a set of common standards question
which obviously will help with public
safety it's obviously uh
something that we want to see is
priority obviously
another area that concerned it's
obviously as we now
hopefully put a lot from this work to
let's move out to consultation
we are now turning a lot of work to
government's arrangements i shall see
from the report
obviously we've got to make sure that uh
the whole thing can function
uh obviously and we are there for
proposing a set out
a clean air management group and
obviously these dams
be established to be responsible for
management on oversight of the gm
clean air service in line with the
policy decisions of the participating
authorities
it's also proposed that a further report
be brought forward
to set up the formal governance
mechanisms that will help underpin
and deliver the clean air plan and the
supporting measures
as you will know the implementation
implementation date even has been
put back but it is now set to come in as
being 2022 and i could not finish
without mentioning attached to the
report is
this the gm response to the government
consultation on the decarbonisation
strategy i sell in
uh section one ten pages of it it's a
very long
section and it's an already long report
but it is very comprehensive
and i would recommend that members have
read it already
do keep that handy it's very positive
and i think that obviously links in
the last item on climate change there
so with that leader i will uh
await any questions and hopefully that's
good leading to that thank you thank you
councillor outside are there any
questions or comments from members of
the executive
now okay we'll move to questions or
comments more wisely councillor jerome
please uh thank you leader i just wanted
to ask the councillor whether
uh reduced speed limits will be
considered in these uh
gm clean air plants thank you
cancer thank you leader uh whilst it's
not directly part of the remit of the
clean air plan which is directly looking
at pollution
and particularly that nitrogen dioxide
as you know
it is covered by the other parts work
that we're actually doing
obviously as you've seen from all parts
of the agenda without having to travel
on the on
on the go very much so as you're very
much aware of and obviously
work that i'm doing around schools and
so forth and that one there
and also there's a lot of work going on
and various sort of aspects and that one
there
uh i've quite got all the details to
hand out this second there but i think
uh
if you want to get back to me on
particular points i'll actually answer
those questions there
in that century but i'll show you
something that we are obviously uh
obviously looking at another item on the
agenda on wednesday which will recover
that particular detail if that's what
you're
alluding to so hopefully we are taking
it on board
and it's covered by a number of
strategies thank
thank you counselor um
okay so are there any other members who
wish to
um come in on this yes chair i put uh
i put a note in the chat all right sorry
i'm watching i'm watching the hand
raised we're going
go on sorry all right i'll do the hand
next time um it's a massive report this
counselor i've said
and and i'm conscious of time etc so
i'll keep it to a few key points
um page 83 uh outlines v
vehicle finance offer to small medium
micro businesses
etc because this is one of my major
concerns one of the federation small
businesses major concerns
um as i understand it roughly the uh
contribution
from gm to people or businesses
will be about three and a half thousand
pound of van
and now bear in mind we've got to
extrapolate this to 2023
and just looking at six year old vans at
this point they're 15 thousand pounds so
we would be asking every business to go
into debt
to the tune of and the difference twelve
and a half thousand
ish at the time even the small jobbing
plumber
etc and i'll move on
and lead sheffield and bristol have
likely to abandon these plans
given covid and the and where we are at
um a report compiled by the federation
of small business
in june uh last year and i don't think
things have moved on because i've been
speaking to people about this
fsb research suggests that the awareness
levels of the proposals amongst
businesses in greater manchester and
beyond
remains low how do how does the gmca
propose
to expand and actually cover everybody
that is going to be affected by
this i've spoken to you know we speak to
an ice cream van
not got a clue speak to a market trader
with a refrigerated van
not got a clue considering we're talking
about a 500 square mile charging zone
upper mill to manchester airport motrum
to standish
it's it's unbelievable it will be the
biggest thing in
the uk probably the biggest in europe
and
that how much we dedicate into marketing
and then that moves on it's a bit
disingenuous of the report itself to say
36 million for preparatory uh works that
fundamentally means cameras to catch
people as they enter gm
um and is it a real consultation
should 80 90 percent of the people that
respond
say you know what we don't really want
this come up with a different plan
is actually going to change it thank you
chet
thanks um councillor evans i will bring
councillor outside in to answer a number
of those but you will be
cognizant of the fact that this is
within my remit
as the green city region lead for
greater manchester um and so just on
that basis a couple of comments on in a
specific
area for me the first is um that it
would not
be a consultation on whether or not
this occurs because we are mandated by
the government
to implement a cassc charging zone
across greater manchester
that is the position and therefore this
is
in effect a consultation on the um
support package and the implementation
of the scheme
but it is a ministerial directive to
implement the scheme
um as currently iterated so that is an
important
clarification to make there um
clearly we want to hear from people
about the proposed support package
and other items related to this but the
nuts and bolts of of what this
looks like in terms of being a cassie
clean air zone um would be a matter to
take up with your government
frankly um in terms of the specific
points
about other areas um and the suggestion
that they were going to scrap
them i think that would be a significant
surprise
not only to them but to the government
and in particular the joint air quality
unit
and i think two of the places that you
mentioned were leeds and bristol so just
for some clarity
on those because you've clearly seen
recent news stories in the media about
bristol's plans
and whilst bristol are working on an
ambitious set of green transport
initiatives
um there is a lot of work still to do in
bristol to understand the impact that
they will have
on air quality and therefore the very
clear direction from the joint air
quality unit to bristol
is that progress must continue on the
clean air zone
whilst in leeds there's been an awful
lot of discussion on their zone
and work is being conducted between
jakku
and leeds to analyze the impact of
kobidon air quality
however um it is expected
that you know the government will
require a considerable amount of
confidence
in ensuring that moving forward
compliance would be achieved
um so it is being looked at but there is
a commitment
to support leads from government in its
ambition which remains
to introduce a clean air zone uh and
preparations
in leeds are continuing in the meantime
to that end
so um that is to ensure as with bristol
that no time is lost if the evidence
suggests that the cause
is still needed so i don't think it's
entirely accurate to say they're going
to be
scrapped there would need to be a
considerable amount of evidence for that
to
be the case and clearly in the meantime
the missive from government remains and
the direction remains in place for those
areas
to implement a clean air zone but i
wonder council lab said he wanted to
comment
on the specifics of the financial
package available and the
other points that councillor evans has
made okay leader uh you've covered some
points there
obviously uh i think there are a couple
something obviously uh if you read
if council having looked through part of
the report it does actually say quite
clearly
in that sense that that quote that
government doesn't accept uh
covered as an excuse for not actually
moving forward on this
nicely as in there and i'm not a
position on that one as leader outline
we are mandated to do this and we have
the government has been taken to court
on a number of occasions actually for
not moving forward on this
and obviously it's down to local
authorities like us to actually
implement these proposals
so in that sense yeah i mean uh there
are a number of
uh impacted groups obviously that we've
been looking at uh
and now you mentioned ice cream vans and
and yes they'll also be things like
burger vans and things like that sort of
thing there's a whole host of vehicles
that uh which were actually one person
operatives that probably
may not be completely aware of it like
yet i think that's part of the
consultation actually now so we can
actually find out
where these last ones are because it's
the amount of types of vehicles is
actually huge
in that sense of it and and um it's been
quite a challenge particularly covered
to actually uh
you know do some of this work on
identifying some of these vehicles so i
think
we're obviously quite keen obviously
that they will affect
the levels of pollution so i think it's
quite like that we can move forward
clean air is a killer in the in the
region as you know
and it's quite rapid but also it's quite
crap they'll actually do work
with businesses to actually minimize uh
the minimum number of
groups that are affected by this and
obviously we've come up with a
c scheme as well from the government as
mandates just move forward on that one
so it's actually right that we work with
these businesses now
and obviously it's working with them
actually find out exactly what their ask
is obviously
we've got some funds there from
government and potentially some others
being looked at there from there
and during this consultation i think we
want to be working in trafford and
across gm
to actually identify the full needs of
those i mean we didn't know
um about the reason why this hat has uh
not before as quickly as possible
and the government accepted that some of
it uh early in the year and last year
was particularly around the uh
second-hand market fleet of compliant
bans which was a struggle because had
all the country gone at the same time
which
some of it was looking at and it's
likely there would have been no
compliance secondhand bans that
to meet the full need across the country
in that century
that was recognized by government and
that's an obviously well
for some strange reason under this uh
capitalist organization when there's
more demand for things
they simply put the price of them up
which is still beyond me actually
why you have the same product at the
same cost but simply because more people
need it
you have to actually increase the cost
of it which is uh just enough way of
making money
also advert for business people as well
in that
so i think it's quite about we get this
right work with those organizations
obviously if you do a particular
concerns do flag them up with ourselves
and officers and we can actually that's
the point of this consultation now
and actually make sure we get this like
moving forward obviously this isn't a
fatal complaint as is suggested
this is just a consultation and that's
the point of actually it is a meaningful
consultation
and i think the government will be
always seeing it never mind was it and
uh
and that gm level it will be overseen
and i think quite rightly
it has to comply with clear uh
guidelines this one and it also
referenced it in and when we do the full
business case in that one
and if we don't get it right then we
leave ourselves open to legal challenge
and i think that's a very serious first
so i think you can you can be ensured
that
every single eye will be dotted and
every t will be crossed
in this whole thing but if you've got
particular issues around particular
businesses
and do speak with us that's that's the
point of this consultation we actually
want to know those uh
with that leader i'll i'll simply leave
those questions unless you want to come
back on those points thank you
thank you for your contribution that was
very helpful thank you councilman said
okay
so um there's nobody else indicating on
this
there are a number of recommendations in
what is an extremely substantial report
the most critical of which is the
approval of moving to
um consultation from next month which is
a a major step forward on what has been
um a significant piece of work so
mindful of the range of recommendations
and members
of the executive happy to approve those
move that [ __ ]
leader i you okay
and then moving on to item eight which
is crossroad bridge sale councillor
patel
please thank you
this is the report for noting and
follows on from the report in june
which announced a public consultation
around the potential redevelopment of
crossfit bridge by sales sharks
in our discussions in june this
executive made it clear that we would
only wish
to move forward with the proposal if it
was supported by local residents
and if the needs of the existing clubs
on site could be met
this report sets out that this first
stage of consultation
did not demonstrate a clear balance of
support for
potential redevelopment of crossfit
bridge from residents or current users
and on that basis we will not be
supporting this proposal moving forward
i would like to thank residents and
clubs for engaging with this
consultation process
i would also like to thank sales sharks
and crossfit futures for conducting what
i believe
was a meaningful and comprehensive
consultation
we are hugely proud of our sporting
heritage in trafford
this council remains committed to
seeking opportunities to bring in
investment for our sporting facilities
and to working with clubs and
communities in an open and transparent
way
thank you
thank you councillor patel are there any
questions or comments from members of
the executive on this
no okay um questions or comments more
widely counselor evans please
thank you thank you chair i'd just like
to thank councillor patel
i'd like to thank yourself personally
and the wider exec for listening to the
residents it
we we all uh thought it was doomed but
thank you
for listening to what the uh people had
to say so that's all i've got to say
thanks no thank you councillor evans for
that
um feedback and perhaps if the previous
administration had not introduced this
proposition into the council in the
first place
um then this would never have even been
taken forward as far as it was that said
it was a potentially
um exciting opportunity so it was right
to ask what residents
and thought of it given the stage that
the previous administration had gotten
to
with it um councillor coggins please
thank you leader just very briefly to
echo councillor evans comments
we have little enough green space and
little enough green belt here in
trafford and i think it's a really
important move to protect this
so just echoing those points thank you
thank you and it is
probably worth noting for members
attention that i have asked the
corporate director place to investigate
village green status for the site
moving forward given the um strength of
feeling from both the clubs
and those living close to the site so
that is something that we
are actively investigating at the moment
okay so this brings us back to um
item nine which obviously has um four
questions outstanding
from earlier before we then move on
to the report itself which is to be
introduced by councillor wright
questions one two and four relate to um
process rather than content of the plan
so i will deal with those with a
collective response but before i do so
um i just wonder if councillor wright
would like to address question three
from jane lester which relates to
um the content of the report and the
hail plan in particular councillor right
yeah thank you leader i'm just think
just just in
in reply to uh jane lester's questions
uh the crossing points on stanford new
road were completed
in spring 2017 following
implementation of these crossings there
were some initial inquiries relating to
how they worked but since that
then there have been no inquiries
received by the council's highways team
in relation to the crossings the council
are also
not aware of any injuries or accidents
relating to anyone using the crossings
and note that they have resulted in a
slight reduction
in vehicle speed on stamford new road
the crossing proposed in hale would not
necessarily be designed in the same way
as those on stanford new road
and would be subject to a full and
detailed design process
including assessment of their impact and
compliance with all the relevant
standards part two
of the answer as part of the process of
preparing the plan
the option of providing a segregated
cycle lane was explored
and a number of possibilities in regards
to cycling facilities have been
discussed with the local community
and key stakeholders in the area however
in order to ensure that we retain the
same number of parking spaces in their
center of hail
which is one of the key messages the
team heard from some of the local
community and businesses
to ensure that pavements are wide enough
and safe for people walking around the
center
and to ensure that businesses have
enough space to seat for seating
outdoors to comply with social
distancing at present
a dedicated cycle lane would not be
feasible
a number of safe and appropriate cycling
facilities are considered appropriate in
the plan
such as those included as part of the
parklet area
on page 52 of the place plan and
additional cycling facilities
park cycle parking facilities i should
say
and part three of the answer as related
to the previous
agenda items on the traffic climate
emergency progress report and the
greater manchester's
clean air plan the council is committed
to ensuring that any development
proposed will support trafford in
reducing
its carbon emissions to meet the climate
emergency
gm and government targets and
commitments on carbon neutrality
any future for more detailed schemes
will follow on from the place plans
will need to adhere to the council's
adopted policies in this regard
the place plans will deliver the
council's climate change
and low carbon agenda by supporting more
sustainable modes of
travel better use of existing land
resource
and promotion of development in
sustainable urban locations
thank you leader thank you councillor
right so turning now to
a single response to the questions of
process received questions one
two and four i'll address those um
directly but obviously
as a a single response to three
questions apologies that it will be
quite a lengthy
response um so work on the hail place
plan
as members are aware commenced in july
2019
from the very beginning we were to
ensure the process in preparing the plan
was inclusive
and are confident that we achieved the
collective response from all members of
the local community the consultant team
led by nexus planning produced an
engagement strategy
detailing how and when people would be
consulted in regards to formulating
proposals
and considering what the overall vision
and objectives were from the outset
so in respect to a timeline of
engagement for hail this was as follows
so
august 2019 the press release was issued
asking for people's views on what they
wanted hail to look like in the future
and ask local people to identify issues
and opportunities
letters were written and hand delivered
to individual businesses in hail in
order to promote consultation and ensure
their involvement
local ward members were invited to a
meeting at the mercure hotel on
wednesday the 3rd of july to brief them
on the nature and scope of work being
undertaken
the initial consultation period ran from
the 8th of august to the 20th of
september last year
with surveys publicized by our online
sources the council's website
and social media accounts were
circulated by local community groups and
organizations
and through hand delivery within the
village itself
and in total in response to that piece
of work 516 local community surveys were
completed in hail
from both businesses and residents an
explanation has been provided in the
report as to why it appears that there
were a low number of business responses
with many businesses telling us that
they completed the resident survey
instead
and i know that this intelligence was
shared with denise labour directly at
the time
um finally from this initial period as
car parking had been raised as a
possible issue
early on in the process a car parking
survey was commissioned and undertaken
by wsp consultants turning then to
october november 2019 throughout october
and november
uh council officers and the consultant
team held meetings with stakeholders
including the owner of the ashley hotel
forward property group and other key
stakeholders in addition
nexus and council officers have
approximately 20 telephone conversations
with denise laver
on behalf of pale civic society to
discuss any concerns that she had with
the plan
which i'm told seemed to relate
primarily to parking
a number of stakeholders were identified
which included residents
local businesses and organizations along
with members from hail central and
adjoining wards
these identified stakeholders were
invited to a meeting at the bowling club
in hail
on the 20th of october last year to go
through some of the findings of the
initial consultation work
and to discuss some of the early
thoughts around what the plan
might include attendees at the event
included ward
local councillors business and
organizations including denise labour on
behalf of pale civic society
moving on to the early part of this year
a public consultation on the draft place
plan for hail was undertaken between the
14th of january
and the 11th of february and to aid this
a permanent exhibition space was set up
in hale library
including boards and hard copies which
were replenished
regularly a survey was publicized
locally both digitally and in person
asking for people to use on the draft
proposals and the findings for
consultation so far
and there were 132 responses to this
survey
in total following this a special
exhibition event was hosted on saturday
the 1st of february at hale bowling club
the event was publicised by a social
media council website and posters were
put up in public places
and a number of local businesses in hail
there were approximately
100 attendees at this event so all of
that brings us
in terms of hail to september this year
where we are now when the final place
plan
was issued to all stakeholders and ward
members for information ahead of this
meeting
the draft place plan contained options
for proposals around the clock tower
ashley road and the bowling club we
sought feedback on the draft plan
and whilst preferred options for some of
the proposals including the clock tower
and bowling green have been included in
the final place plan
this has been amended and developed in
light of comments arising at the
consultation stage
and so i reject the suggestion that no
consideration has been given to
the feedback received turning to sale
more and mr jojo's suggestion the
council's not allowed any consultation
on the sale or more place plan
this is demonstrably not the case and
indeed mr jojo himself attended one such
consultation event
um given mr jojo was clearly aware of
this event
in order to attend it and engage in the
process um albeit in a
somewhat less than constructive way from
the feedback that i have received from
officers and councillors who were
present
i don't see how it can possibly be
argued that the council failed to warn
advise
inform or allow input into the plan and
i particularly object to the suggestion
that this has been dealt with in an
underhanded way as per mr jojo's
comments in his question
it's worth noting that with regard to
the sale more place plan consultation we
went above and beyond that
originally planned in terms of our
engagement with the community
adding in additional consultation
meetings at the weekend to increase
awareness and
interest in the plan businesses have
letters hand delivered to them
to make them aware of the plan and
posters were put up in a number of units
in the village
sale moore's initial consultation last
august and september yielded 317
responses from the local community
the further consultation event held on
the 1st of february at salem methodist
church was attended by more than 300
people
again suggesting a reasonably high level
of awareness
as with the hail place plan all
identified stakeholders were sent a copy
of the final plan
in advance of this meeting and so again
i would reject mr jojo's assertion
that this has been dealt with in an
underhanded way or indeed in some sort
of covert
action overall then i'm confident that
the process followed
throughout has been robust in the case
of both of these plans and would like to
thank the officers
involved in this work and in particular
damian cutting
um with specific reference to the
suggestion within mr clark's question
that this has been a somehow
undemocratic process we've not only
followed the usual democratic route for
decision making within the council on
this item
but have done so after extensive public
consultation engaging with hundreds of
local residents and stakeholders
i reject the suggestion therefore that
this is undemocratic or indeed that the
communities of hail or sale more
have been ignored simply because some
within the community do not agree with
the content of the plans
no plans such as this would ever carry
100 support in the locality concerned
but this does not in any way mean the
views of the community have not been
taken into consideration
and indeed we can clearly evidence where
this has happened within the final
versions
that sit before members this evening so
that
concludes the response to the public
questions but there is a further
relevant fact supplementary to the
concerns of the questioners
that i do want to make members of the
executive aware of before we deliberate
on this matter
colleagues should also be aware that
we've all as members of cabinet
received an email this afternoon on a
without prejudice basis
questioning the process and raising the
prospect of potential legal challenge
members should be aware that i've
discussed this issue with the monitoring
officer
and the written response of the points
made will be provided in due course
however whilst this is a relevant fact
for members to be aware of before coming
to a decision
i'd advise executive members further
that following that discussion with the
monitoring officer
i'm satisfied the process was both
robust and lawful in terms of how we
consulted on this
matter and so we do not believe that
this should prevent us taking the
decision on the matter
in this meeting today um so now that
members are fully
appraised of the situation surrounding
this item i'll ask councillor right to
introduce the report
councillor right please
[Music]
thank you leader thank you for allowing
me to introduce this paper firstly i'd
like to thank all of our staff in
particular uh damien damien cutting
our nexus planning for putting together
these documents which have been a really
in-depth piece of work
they've provided a paper which provides
an exciting vision for both salem or and
hail
and re-emphasizes this council's
commitment to all areas of our borough
both salem or and hale are important to
much loved
villages within our borough and i
believe these plans provide an exciting
vision
that will further enhance their standing
into the future
i'm going to start with the hail plan
firstly i would just like to point out
the fantastic response response we got
from the community during the
consultation
and just to make the point that this
administration believes in seeking
residents views to begin with
not imposing them on communities like
the previous administration
64 percent of resident of respondents
think that the vision for hell village
center appropriately reflects
the aspirations of the local community
sixty percent agreed or strongly agree
with the objectives of the plan
and the vision 59 agree or strongly
agree
with the public realm objectives 71
agreed with the introduction of a shock
frontage strategy
the vision for hail pays tribute to
promoting sustainable modes of transport
and moving away from reliance up from a
reliance on cars
to create pedestrian and cycle access
through the village that will be safe
and secure
and to make the center family-friendly
through the creation of new community
spaces
this is a modern and progressive vision
vision for sale
town centre should not be a place where
the car dominates any further
it is not just this council that
believes in that either
the current government also believes in
it
one of the most poignant parts of the
plan is on page 11
where we see an historic view of the
hale village centre in comparison to the
current view of the hal village center
what struck me was the much more
inviting nature of the historic photos
a village with space for pedestrian not
devoid of cars
but not dominated by cars following the
end of the covey lockdown and the easing
of the restrictions in may
grant shaps the secretary of state for
transport
announced a two billion pound fund to
boost cycling what cycling and walking
this included a 250 million pounds up
front to create a pop-up cycle lane some
of which we have had in this borough as
i'm sure you will have noticed
mr shap stated fast tax fast track
statutory guidance to cater for
significantly increased cycling and
walking
would be implemented immediately
as a council we have also signed up to
the manchester clean airplane and
declared a climate emergency in trafford
we cannot carry on with the status quo
villages such as hail can thrive even
more with a changing environment
more space for walking more space for
cycling
cleaner air for people visiting the
village
more outside space for restaurants and
bars
more community space for families the
ability to close the village to cars
should the v should the community want
to to hold special events such as
festivals
or christmas activities
despite all this the hail place plan
actually provides a net gain
in parking bays of 11. you will note
that on the parking survey there was
ample capacity across the village during
peak periods
and this may be anecdotal but having
gone into hail on both saturday morning
and this morning
there was also plenty of parking
available then
however because the parking bays have
been relocated in some areas
the environment created on pages pages
328 to 338 of the plan
allow for a much more inviting village
one that is no longer
dominated by the car to summarize the
hail place plan builds on the fantastic
place that hail is
but also provides a vision for its
future
town and village centres are changing
the world is changing
this plan not only enhances what is
already great about hail
but proposes to contemporize a village
into a place that everyone can visit and
enjoy
i'll now move on to sale more
the response to consultation again was
fantastic 64 percent of respondents
agreed or strongly agreed with the
objectives relating to the offer of the
center
58 agree with the movement's objectives
64 agreed with the streetscape
movements 63 percent agreed with the
public realm objectives
a comfortable majority of respondents
the vision for samoa states salmore will
be a thriving village center with
community at its heart
people will be able to move about freely
and sell more will become accessible to
everyone at all times of the day
with sustainable movement as its heart
as with hail the vision for salmore is
to make it more accessible
less dominated by the car and become a
much better environment for people to
visit
again one of the most poignant parts of
the report were the historic photos of
salmore on page 10.
the photo in the bottom left-hand corner
of the page represents a thriving
village
center with space very little vehicle
usage in a much more welcoming
environment
the major issue with salmore even more
so than hail
is the domination of the car
the gyratory system was one of the
strongest weaknesses identified by the
community on page 19 of the report
and the lack of opportunities across the
main streets within the center
the plan looks to tackle those issues
and improve the environment
of sail more if you have ever visited
salmore you will note how narrow the
footpaths are
and on a busy saturday morning how
difficult it is to navigate your way
down the street to the various excellent
i saw one who had their wedding cake
made by the fantastic top tier cakes a
few years ago
i know the importance of the local
businesses and the contribution that
they make both of the village
and to the borough as a whole however
giving the community
more space and reducing the usage and
domination of the car throughout the
village
can only be a beneficial thing there are
plenty of ostrich car parking areas
within salemore that are underused
if you look at page 47 of the plan for
example
the illustration shows a much more
inviting centre
which thrives on more space for
pedestrians
the the development strategy for warren
street also provides a huge
opportunity for sale more to create a
community space
new homes and bring a residential mix
into the village can only
enhance the sustainability of the
village centre
i think we all accept that town and
village centres are changing
with more focus being placed on
residential units in town centres
to complement the retail and hospitality
on offer
this view was before the covid crisis
this view will only become stronger as
we hopefully move into a post-covered
world
the salem all plan provides an exciting
vision for the village
it provides it builds on the fantastic
array of businesses already present
and the community spirits and
environment that already exists
the vision and plan safeguards it
improves the village's future
and like hale gives the village a
contemporary and progressive plan
to move forward with i ask that the
executive approves the report
thank you later thank you councillor
wright
um any questions or comments from
members of the executive
i have um councillor patel please
thank you leader i very much welcome
hail and salem or place plans
and they i feel that they represent an
overdue and significant recognition of
our village centres
which play a huge role in our
communities and our local economy
providing long-term planning and design
visions for these areas will help
support and sustain them in the future
whilst recognizing there are lots of
different views and demands on our
village centers
i'm proud that we have prioritized
people over cars in this in these
visions
contrary to some fears there is growing
evidence that traffic calming and
enhancing pedestrian environments
in commercial spaces can drive up
footfall and encourage people to spend
longer in these areas
indeed plans to remove street barriers
and enhance public realm
will benefit the 79 percent of people
who currently walk into salem or village
reconfiguring parking may feel
challenging to some individual
businesses but i know that the broad
vision in salem or maintains a
reasonable
level of on-street parking whilst
enhancing pedestrian space
maintains access for blue badge holders
and makes more of our currently
under-utilized car parks
there will be no overnight changes this
is what
this is about what our villages will
look like in 20 years
and there will of course be further
consultation ahead of an
ahead of any funded proposals in the
future thank you
thank you councillor patel councillor
freeman please
thank you leader i think the village
place plans for salmon hell should be
welcomed by residents
for far too long the focus of this
council has been around activities in
our town centers our distinct villages
have been ignored
so these plans are addressing that
balance so i'm therefore proud to be
part of a labour administration that has
enabled this
the plans for both villages set out a
clear vision for how these distinct
areas can continue to improve
sustainability
and develop so i do hope those small
groups that are uncomfortable with the
plans
and the proposals within will take a
step back to reflect on this
the information in the plans makes it
clear the plans are not inflexible
nor are they prescriptive and of course
contrary to what
some would have you believe the changes
are not going to happen as councilor
patel said overnight
what these plans do is help establish a
clear vision and development strategy
for their area
establish clear development and design
principles to be used as material
consideration
in the determining of future planning
applications and in that way
will support the delivery of traffic's
new local plan when it's published
the key question residents and
businesses need to ask themselves is
what will my village look like in 10 20
or 30 years time
these plans provide for that vision and
therefore should be welcomed
now before i finish i'd like to address
some of the things that have been said
over the past few days on social media
by councillor evans councillor evans
you've described the presenting of these
plans to executive tonight for approval
as underhanded i think you need to
retract that assertion and apologize
the use of the word underhanded is a
direct attack on the integrity and the
hard work of council officers
that the hard work the council offices
have put into delivering these
delivering these plans you have further
asserted
that the views of businesses have been
ignored in these plans despite the
consultations that have taken place
you could not be more wrong and your
focus on what you and your and others
perceive to be an immediate threat to
the village as we currently know them
is utterly misplaced and frankly
politically motivated
you can shout you can bully all you want
on social media
but i'd remind you that your party had
14 years of controlling trafford
to do something about the future
sustainability of our villages
and in that time you did nothing i am
supporting these place plans because
they will help to serve the needs of our
residents in trafford going forward
over the next 10 20 30 years helping to
protect what they hold most dear
that is our village centers thank you
leader
thank you councillor freeman i'm now
going to open up more widely and i think
um given that we've just heard from two
cell more members we will start off with
the
ward members for hail central i've got
indications from
um counselors mrs dad and mrs young
so um council haddad would you like to
come in
hi can you hear me yes good
um counselor wright and you make an
elaborate statement that you
had a fantastic response
uh how can you justify that
in the light how can you justify that it
was a meaningful
consultation and that occurred
in the light of the following the first
uh firstly the council consultation on
the first and
second draft of the hale village plan
only resulted in a total of
642 community responses
the population of the hail village
is over fifteen thousand so the
community response
the response rate was four percent
secondly the second consultation led to
a total of nine
business responses there are
approximately
325 businesses in hail
so the response rate among businesses
is less than three percent less than
three percent
in addition a consultation meeting
held at the cottage earlier this year
was attended by
15 to 20 people
it's not clear that the council made
sufficient
effort to engage with faith groups
the heritage society the businesses
and many charitable organizations within
trafford
within hale in summary
and the consultation engaged very few
people and cannot be regarded as a
representative
of opinion of the hail community
i'd further like to ask
it is how how the um
strategy how the changes to the drafts
were made
because it's unclear what changes were
made
after the initial and the second draft
as a result of the consultation
albert that the consultation was
inadequate
and finally there has been evidence
of overwhelming opposition
to this hail village plan in its current
format
the evidence and to me as a counselor
has been i've been contacted by many
residents
businesses and charitable groups
to to who are unhappy with the
consultation
and do not feel it was adequate
the evidence adds further weight to the
argument that the consultation
was inadequate and cannot be regarded as
representing the views and opinions of
the major stakeholders
i call on the council to postpone
tonight's decision on the hale village
plan
and to commence a new consultation
a full and meaningful consultation thank
you
thank you and councilman young please
and thank you for letting me speak
leader
as a hill central ward councillor
i have contacted officers and other
members numerous times
regarding the hail place plan as i have
many concerns with the plan
not least regarding parking concerns and
the survey used as part of the
consultation
as recently as the 19th of september i
wrote to counsellor wright requesting a
breakdown
of the number of surveys and emails
received
that were not in favor of the proposals
and their reasons why
i didn't receive a response to that
question
can the executive member please tell me
why that question
has again not been answered as i am
receiving daily emails on this matter
from hale central residents who were
unhappy with the proposed plan
thank you thank you
um councilman young i will um
ask councillor wright whether he wants
to come back on those or take all
contributions together
at the end i'm just conscious we've got
a number of speakers
what would you like to do count to the
right i'm happy to i'm happy to take
um take the the majority of those um
now if that's okay leader yeah i think
it will be easier
yeah just in relation to the email that
counselor young
um has sent to me i i don't recall
receiving it councillor
i can only apologize if i've not
responded to you but i will
i will have a look into my emails and
respond to you in due course on that so
my apologies
um in relation to the consultation uh
from
questions from counsellor dad i think
the leader has provided
a fair enough response to that so far in
a very detailed response to questions
from the public
and i disagree with councillor that's a
dad's comments regarding consultation
we actually went above and beyond our
statutory consultation processes with
this one
and i'm i i i couldn't disagree any more
on that front
um and um just just in relation to the
opposition that you've received from
members of the hail community in
relation to
the uh consultation process again um as
as the leader has stated we have been
through a proper consultation process
um and um just in relation to
uh postponing this report um
unless the leader tells me differently
um that will not be happening this
evening will be proceeding
as normal thank you thank you
councillor right we will move on to
um actually although it's not
technically in his ward i think a little
corner of it are butts so on a similar
theme i will bring
councillor boys in who's got some
questions on the sale more
place plan please
i'll let you look at me as well uh
leader thank you very much indeed i
would actually say that
it does actually uh a bot it's just
doesn't just but
um there is a part of uh conway road
and marsman road which is within the
bounds
of the plan anyway and so yeah a small
part but nevertheless
a significant number of brooklyn's
residents
actually would i think you would wish to
be
attracted back to samoa anyway um i have
a number of questions but before that
i'd say reference the
invitation to meetings the initial
invitation to meetings
to local members i can say that having
lived within half a mile of sale more
for over 45 years i did attend to
express my significant concerns
about many aspects of the proposals
although i must state that i was the
only member who attended that session
from the three awards involved i have
five questions really for council are
right
all of which i think you'll appreciate
probably are are
in fact traffic related first
are you certain that the single
carriageway westbound at 20 miles an
hour
will cope with the volume of traffic
which currently arrives from junction 6
of the m60
and along the b5166 from northern mall
bearing in mind that in recent years
many more southbound commuters leave the
a56 at m60
junction 7 to then drive and exit at
junction 6
onwards to drive through sail more to
access brooklyn's and beyond
second question are you certain that the
proposed
uncontrolled t-junction by the jehovah's
witness hall
will work without a causing unacceptable
delays and therefore
tailbacks towards sail along northern
road
and b causing unacceptable tailbacks
towards northern moor
when vehicles are forced to queue behind
others driving westbound
which are turning right towards sail and
have to give way to oncoming traffic
three do you accept that since traffic
from brooklyn
or south of salem or cannot turn right
by the immo car wash they will then have
to divert via derbyshire road
alexandra road princess road etc
in order to access the hampton and
watson street car parks
causing congestion on residential roads
were the plans amended to allow the
right turn
would this not then produce yet further
potential tailbacks
four development of the wire street car
park
site is noted as an essential part of
the overall plan
do you have any estimate of the length
of time
that the warner street car park might be
closed
whilst it is excavated to provide below
ground parking
which is a part of the development of
that part of the plan
5. do not feel that it might have been
wise to conduct a full
traffic survey before designing a
traffic layout
which effectively takes us back to where
we were more than 30 years ago
when the then volume of traffic far less
than today
demanded a design which effectively did
away with the t
junction thank you
thank you and again on the theme of
working through
um questions that relate to individual
um
board member concerns counselor right
i'll i'll ask you if you want to come in
on this cognizant that you would be
well within your rights to um offer a
response from a traffic engineer to some
of those specific questions
um but counselor right yeah thank you
ladies and you sort of pre-empted me
there i i am not a traffic engineer
so i wouldn't be able to answer answer
some fairly technical questions that
have been asked of me there to be
perfectly honest
um i'm i'm happy to take those questions
away with me though councillor boys and
come back to you with a response from
uh our traffic specialists but um in
relation to the questions that you asked
apart from question four in relation to
the excavation which i may be able to
bring richard in about um the other
one's a very technical traffic question
so i wouldn't be
in a place to answer them i'm afraid at
this stage
okay richard do you want to comment on
any any comments you would have
as the director over our highways um
specifically though the the question on
um warren street
thank you leader in relation to the the
specific highways questions i'm not a
highways engineer either i would refer
to my technical colleagues if councillor
boys would like to send those questions
in in writing then i'm sure
i will ensure that we get a full
response to him um
in terms of uh the works how long it
will take on the works for
warren street that in any development
inevitably takes a period of time and
there's a there's a
an element of disruption that comes from
that
in general you would expect a
development of this scale to take
somewhere in the region of 12 to 18
months
but but that's that's a very broad
figure even though we've not done that
detailed work on
the assessment and the impact of that in
terms of displacement of car parking is
something that would have to be taken
into account and considered as part of
those redevelopment plans
thank you
thank you i will send the questions in
to
buyer by richard rowe with my specific
traffic questions are there um
and i would actually perhaps finish by
saying that i mean the concerns are
my concerns are significantly about
traffic movement
it's not about the concept of a uh
an overall plan for the for the village
but i would quote one of the businesses
that i spoke to in terms of
particularly concerns about uh parking
and access to
hamston street or watson street car
parks
or the warren street when it's out of
action and the comment was don't they
realize
that if i had a one percent reduction in
my turnover
because people were not accessing the
village i would go
bust thank you council of boys
who increase the walkability and cycle
ability of the village whether i've
heard one okay
and we'll move on to councillor welton
please
thank you leader um i have to say that
the the the scale of ambition in
in sale more has to be uh has to be
applauded this is exactly the kind of
change to our highways that we
that we need if we're going to get
anywhere close
to um to the uh
the requirements that have been set out
in the emphasis report today
business as usual is no is no longer
good enough unfortunately in the hail of
the the hail village plan um really that
is
very much business as usual it's
cosmetic improvements that we see there
it's incredibly meek and i think i'm
absolutely shocked by the uh
by the um scale of the outcry that
seemed to
very manufactured outcry that is coming
from the uh from
the pro on street parking lobby um you
know
unfortunately i feel that they've got
everything they wanted in this report
yet yet
we still hear we still hear these angry
voices
um they have got retained through
traffic through hail village they've got
parking on both sides of the street um
and now somehow there's a petition out
that seems to be complaining that the
street is too narrow
despite the fact that they've got you
know of course it's going to be narrow
if you've got parking on both sides of
the street and you're trying to use the
pavement
for um you know for for for dining and
for the businesses to expand
expand on and for social distancing um
it seems like there is a lobby that will
never be satisfied
and while we try to satisfy them we will
never
be particularly inhale we won't be able
to come up with the pound plans that we
need to make hail fit for the next
you know for the next century and to
meet our targets within
the answers plan the clean air plans all
these things that keep that public
health manifesto
you know and so while i i'd like to ask
so while
while the move to a uh and i would like
to say that the move towards a 20 mile
an hour limit
is great in hail and very welcome in
sale more but while the hail village
plan
retains through traffic and on street
parking on both sides of ashley road
how exactly is this plan a move away
from the reliance on cars
that is promised in the planned text
himself
thank you thank you um i'll bring
councillor wrighton again
um james
thank you leader yeah i mean i would say
that i think this is this is a
an ambitious plan uh for hail and that
we we are moving away from the dominance
of the car in hail
um and i think it's a small step in the
right direction um
i think i mean just just i think i think
just to address some of the concerns
that have been raised by
uh from the opposite side just in
relation to what you said that
the retailers often overestimate the
importance of their car
of their car on their businesses um and
uh and there's plenty of studies that
that that suggest that and i'm happy to
share that with any any any concern
members
uh going forward but just in relation to
the uh the sort of the greening of hail
and
and bringing back more of the center to
the community
the ability to um to create more space
for businesses the ability
for cycle parking which we know brings
more business to town centres as well
i think it's a i think it's quite an
ambitious plan for hail
now it may not be as ambitious as
councillor welton
would like it to be at this stage um but
i think this is a progressive move in
the right direction
um and i i'm i'm quite proud of what the
officers have
brought about here i really am thank you
thank you councillor right
and um final speaker is councillor evans
thank you chair um i think the four
questions presented to the executive
uh quite indicative of what the uh
the residents feel about it i know we i
don't think we've ever had four
questions
at an executive um just a shame we can't
get them online i hope they understand
um but uh leader i appreciate your
answers um i've got to
address councillor freeman because he's
asked me to um
he thinks residents should welcome these
plans well
councillor freeman i'll tell them that
i'll tell them that you think they
should welcome them because they
certainly don't
and in respect in response to councilman
freeman regarding delivering for
trafford
i've not had a chance to do an
exhaustive list
and i appreciate sale more without a
doubt needs a plan there is no doubt
nobody is querying that and probably
nobody is querying the need for one
inhale
but for trafford we delivered at
university ua 92
we redeveloped partington ernst high
street the whole of altering
altering them to best high street we had
the best recycling in greater manchester
three new libraries and a metro link to
trafford park
i apologize when we were in control we
didn't source out so more and it
certainly does need
sort out with respect to under-handed
councillor freeman
i wouldn't use that phrase if the
businesses
and i had to be fair i only spoke to
five and it only came out
from an accidental conversation not a
single one
knew of this meeting this evening to
decide their
fate that's how i arrived at underhanded
that's it you you could have been out
telling them it ended up me
chance conversation turning to council
of welter now i'm conscious this is not
a council meeting
and i apologize leader and it is too
narrow
the parking bays that are planned do not
accommodate
the average car that's parked in hail
they're just not wide enough
and but it is also clear from councillor
wealth and there's no need to take the
residents on these journeys
because we know best what is best for
the residents
and but it's clear the businesses are
both hail and sale more were totally
unaware
until last week that these plans were
anywhere near
completion and they are fundamentally at
completion
because we're taking a decision tonight
should the plans have been that great
why weren't officers and other members
out speaking to the businesses because
it is going to impact them
massively uh the five i spoke to
totally unaware and that was sale more
but the bigger objections are coming
from the hail residents who
raised too many queries and actually
it's not about
thrashing through the plan here and
i've never had as many emails about
anything uh
ever and i understand that the executive
has probably had
probably even more emails and queries
about revolving around the legitimacy of
the consultation
and the responses given by the leader
just now attempts to address the
legitimacy of the consultation
fundamentally take the boxes
but fails to address the need to take
the community along this journey
the community doesn't feel consulted
they believe they haven't been consulted
the online petition that is online that
is there now
has garnered more responses than
the uh consultation itself
hail 300 businesses nine responses
the federation of small businesses
survey 170 businesses responded
giving us the total opposite to the
results you've come up with tonight
and it's we've heard it's likely to be
if this is adopted we could well end up
with a legal challenge that's not a
threat that's probably where we are the
the strength of feeling is massive and
but it is also
all too clear that the administration
tends to impose these
on the on the villages i will finish
actually on a positive note
well you have listened to the residents
of dane road and
and they've got the result that those
residents want
these residents and the businesses are
only asking for a delay
they're not asking for it to be
cancelled tonight just does not seem
the time mid covered to
take this decision so it's a plea really
give them an opportunity to actually
engage
they don't feel you've engaged with them
simple as that thank you leader for the
time i appreciate that
thank you councillor evans um
i'm going to allow councillor right
first bite at the cherry i think
thank you leader appreciate that yeah
i'm not going to go over all ground on
the consultation but
a couple of things i will just just come
back on uh you mentioned there was only
there's been four questions
uh asked at the executive on this issue
uh which you believe is the highest ever
um recorded um we've only been having
questions
exactly for just over 12 months because
we introduced them as administration
your administration
didn't um so i'll just make that point
um and just in relation to the petition
that you mentioned councillor evans
um the petition is um states that um
trafford wants to pedestrianize hail
i'm pretty sure that the majority would
be a much bigger majority of people who
wouldn't want the pedestrianization of
hell and of course that's not what is in
the plan we are not planning to
pedestrianize hail
so why the petition is in relation to
that i have no idea
um thank you leader i'm sure you'll want
a second bite of the cherry on this one
no no i think you you've more or less
covered it here i mean
the only other thing that i'd had about
the petition is that it's currently
showing 645 signatories on the online
petition which is less than the uh
651 total responses to the consultation
so um if counselor mrs sadat's claim
that this was a woeful
response to a consultation is true then
i can only draw my own conclusions as to
the response to what is as counselor
wright said an extremely hyperbolic
um petition which does not reflect what
is actually happening
in the village that said um you know we
we have
evidenced significant consultation here
we have
evidence changes to the plan that have
happened as a result of
the uh consultations in both hail and
sale more and we are articulating the
first
vision um for any of our village centers
that i can recall in trafford and so
whilst we have
councillor evans's list none of that
actually addressed
the um point that councillor freeman was
making which is that when it comes to
not only sale more but
hail village as well i cannot remember
a great deal that you did at all in 14
years in control of this council for
either of those areas other than of
course to threaten to close hail library
and let the community step in and save
it so
it is somewhat challenging to meet this
level of resistance
um when this administration is
attempting to move our village centers
forward and
can evidence from what are and i
appreciate
people will always argue not enough not
enough not enough
in terms of response rates but extremely
high
response rates in my experience to
consultations such as this
which unfortunately often do have
extremely low
response rates and 600 plus in the case
of hail
is not extremely low and 300 people
attending an event at salem or methodist
church is also not
extremely low indeed this shows a
positive level of engagement from
the communities and of course in both
cases
showed clear majority support for the
plans
so on that basis i am moving the
recommendations as set out
in the report are members of the
executive happy to
approve those hi thank you
okay so moving on to
the next item on the agenda which is the
corporate plan quarter one report
council freedom please
uh thank you leader um
the paper before you presents the first
quarter report for 2021
and the review of the corporate plan on
the page which was promised would be
undertaken
following the first full year of the
corporate plan executive are asked to
note the contents of the quarter one
report
and approve the changes to the overall
plan are set out in paragraph
four four four five and appendix 2 of
the report
as you'll be aware the council
identified 7 strategic priorities
that we believe are crucial to enabling
traffic residents businesses and staff
to thrive
these priorities set out the aspirations
of our people place and communities and
how they can affect
and approve their daily lives the
corporate plan
describes how these priorities will be
delivered over three years
april 2019 to march 2022
this will ensure that staff partners and
residents understand the actions
required for the council
and identify the resources available to
deliver
the stated aims and objectives the plan
helps the council and teams
the plan helps the council and teams to
monitor performance and make use of the
opportunities presented
and control our systems and structures
effectively
i'll deal first with the corporate plan
quarter one performance
the quarter one report provides a
summary of performance from the first of
april to the 30th of june 2020
this period was impacted by the
coronavirus pandemic
each priority has a summary of activity
for quarter one
these activities are a combination of
qualitative and quantitative activity
and the output for each quarter depends
on the deliverables that are achieved
for that quarter
the key performance indicators on page 4
of the report are in
red amber and green in status
for any indicator of target with the red
status an exception report has been
prepared
to outline why performance is below
target and what actually is in place to
improve performance
for quarter one 2020 there are two
indicators with the red status
and the exception reports have been
completed i'll now move on to a plan on
the page
the plan on the page is a summary of the
council's ambitions
for delivery over a three-year period
april 19 to march 2022
as we have completed the first year of
the corporate plan it is now necessary
to review the plan on the page to take
account of any new priorities
and key deduples we always said we would
constantly review an update
and after the first year and the
unprecedented changes and challenges we
have faced it is appropriate
to revisit all aspects and refine as
necessary
there are three deliverables in red on
the pen on the page which we are subject
which
will are to be removed from the plan as
it is not feasible to achieve
this is implement a sustainable new
primary care mental health service
as a service advisor this is no longer
possible specifically the sustainable
element
uh install a bespoke wireless network
across the borough to improve
connectivity
as a service is advised this is no
longer possible across the borough
and introduce safe space places scheme
as it has been agreed
with gmca that this project is halted
due to limited take-up
and the funding has been used for a
different project
the deliverables in amber are to be
placed with more relevant
outcomes so we have deliver a clear
public service reform
and strategy for chapters new ways of
working to be replaced by develop and
deliver
the traffic together health and social
care recovery locality plan
and our three aspirations better lives
for our most vulnerable people
better well-being for our population and
better connections throughout our
communities
the next one is develop and deliver to a
children and young people plan
this is to be placed by develop and
deliver the improvement plan
the final one improve education
attainment levels for children eligible
for free school meals and looked after
children
this is to be replaced with improved
education attainment levels
for children eligible for free school
meals looked after children
and children with special educational
needs i commend the report to the
executive and i'm about to take
questions later thank you
thank you councillor freeman any
questions or comments from members of
the executive
any questions or comments more wildly
councillor evans i'm not sure if your
hand is still up from last time or you
wanted to come in feel free if you do
it's last ladies from last time i'll
lower it down apologies
no worries um i don't think there's
there's anybody else to come
in on this so um if we can
um take those recommendations please the
executive are we happy to approve those
i i
okay and then the final substantive item
is the period for
budget monitor councillor ross please
thank you i'll try to be brief because i
know this report's already had a
extensive discussion at uh pandello's
pandemic scrutiny
last week the current forecast for
this year at period four is an overspend
of
2.248 million to which we will apply
corporate reserves however i have to
caveat that with a huge health warning
these figures date back to before the
most recent
restrictions were announced by the the
government last week and it is still
very early in the financial year so
the the numbers could change for for
this year
um you will find in the report also
there's greater detail around the
capital free program including what's
been re-profiled into future years
and if i may um because i know
particularly councillor myers has
asked about this a couple of times in
exec i've got a little bit of
information about the uh
the grant we received for brexit which
again is something that's becoming
president as we move into october
and so i just wanted to confirm to
colleagues that um we were we've been
given a brexit preparedness grant
of 315 000 pounds two posts
have um have been um set up as a result
of that
um and that's uh meant that a 135 000 of
that grant has been allocated
one was to a strategic growth um
position and another to all age
commissioning
the remaining grant of 180 000 pounds we
are
keeping a close eye on what's happening
over the next few weeks with the
negotiations that are going on and what
the likelihood is regarding a
no deal brexit we will then um meet
as a transition impact group to look at
how best to use that money
as we go ahead so at the moment we're
not only still managing the coverage
situation but we've also got the brexit
situation which will of course have
an impact on what we do as an authority
but very happy to take any questions
thank you councillor ross any questions
or comments from
members of the executive no okay we'll
move more widely councillor myers please
yes thank you leader i'm very grateful
to councillor ross for his information
about the
the uh the brexit grant that's been very
helpful thank you very much
uh turning to this report in front of us
now can i refer him to
page 179 and section 17
and 19 which discusses the shortfall in
council tax collection
of uh four and a half million pounds
apart from being able to spread the cost
um
for our tax liability over a three year
period
could councillor ross outline the steps
that he will be taking
to plug the gap and also to help
residents who are struggling financially
thank you thank you council ross
okay um obviously the the reprofiling of
that um
that money into future years is
something that the government is
allowing us to do
which takes the short-term pressure off
of this particular budget but adds two
pressures down the line so
in terms of um in in terms of that what
would be
useful is if the government would um
cover
the uh the money that we've lost the
money that we're likely to lose as a as
a local authority not just this year but
in future years as was originally set
out
at the start of the the pandemic in
terms of the
wider assistance to people um we
are looking at and we've still got our
council tax support package
and we obviously have trafford assistant
other
agencies and that will be able to
provide advice and support to people
that
find themselves in the unfortunate
position where they're no longer able to
pay council tax because they're out of
work and i have to say again
it's it's a very salient point patrick
because
we're facing mass unemployment coming up
across the country i think we've not had
mass unemployment as a as an issue in
this country for
nearly 30 years now and so the
collective memory of it
is not as great as it it it could be
um obviously we will react as an
authority
as more people find themselves going on
to universal credit
and in need of support that is something
that we will react to you have my
assurance there
and hopefully though the government will
put in measures that will mitigate
and potential long-term unemployment
because it is a scourge
on this society and it is something that
we desperately want to avoid
thank you councillor ross and um
councillor coggins
thank you leader um very briefly at
paragraph 39 you discuss the development
and land sales programs and we're told
that work is ongoing to see if any of
the development schemes
might be moved to straight land sales um
in order to
get a a quicker turnaround i'm
interested to know whether
um the work on the cow fields also known
as land of stockholm avenue in
altringham
might be um one of the ones that are
being considered
currently a development scheme thank you
thanks
thank you i don't have an immediate
answer to that councillor coggins but i
am sure that um
richard made richard maybe i'll say
something now otherwise we'll get
something written to you
richard any any input on that or we can
just we can follow up if needed
yeah just to confirm that's not one of
the sites that we are
looking at moving into a straight
disposal
and um councillor jerome please
um it was sad to see that uh one of
chaffer's biggest employer's cartwrights
went into administration recently and
you and you spoke about
mass unemployment have you got any
measures in mind for
trying to help businesses through this
very tricky period
thank you again that's a that's an
important question throughout the
summer and the strategic growth team
have been supporting
businesses um no no you know mainly
through the
the grant but also through other advice
um i know we'll be working with the
combined authority with with the mayor
of greater manchester
in terms of looking at the region as a
whole and how we um how we support
businesses
in in in that respect but no i have to
pay tribute to our
colleagues the officers in the strategic
growth team because i know firsthand
the amount of advice and guidance that
they've given to businesses
so far um during the pandemic and
obviously we were keen to support our
businesses as best we can
as a borrower within the resources that
we have as we move forward because the
more people that are employed
and the more thriving businesses we have
the better all around
oh andrew you just on me
thank you tom um i think that's the
first time i've done that maybe
anyway um so no further questions or
comments on that
um can the recommendations to be noted
be approved
thank you okay um there are no items
of urgent business um and no need
obviously for the exclusion resolution
so i will bring
the meeting to a close thank you
everybody um
for your attendance take care thank you
okay